hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of
stuff to talk about on Teen Wolf this
week so what I'm gonna do is because I
missed last week I'm gonna combine
episode 8 episode 9 in this video I'm
gonna do a quick run-through of the
biggest stuff from episode 8 and then
just do episode 9 like I usually do my
videos I feel like the last couple of
weeks have really shown why MTV chose
not just to renew it for season 5 but
for a full 20 episodes so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the
episodes yet but starting with episode 8
commentary my ocean panic moment from
the episode was really Derek losing his
powers were a little past halfway in
this season we still have no idea what's
going on with Kate and what she did to
him I totally hate that it's destroying
him but I love the Derek that he's
turning into so think back to seasons 1
& 2 Derek he was a total dick he is so
much cooler now he's like the obi-wan
Kenobi big brother to everyone so much
more sympathetic Tyler hoechlin is
definitely gonna make everybody cry a
lot before the season finale he's not
dying or anything he's coming back for
Season 5 this shows not getting rid of
him despite what the banshee predicted I
don't think he's hit rock bottom yet
things are still gonna get worse but if
he does have to get his ass handed to
him at least he's got Braden which was a
great sex scene by the way it wasn't HBO
levels of skin but I am really happy to
see them together I also love the way
that they paired his sex scene visually
with that table full of guns there is so
much imagery there I could spend like
six videos talking about that which
actually leads me to the big benefactor
reveal it's a banshee only they can
confirm death without seeing a body and
then there's Scott's death sequence that
was actually pretty cool wasn't quite as
trippy as the ones during season three
but I like the way that it used the Liam
I think it's Scott's unconscious mind
just processing his fears like he has
alpha powers but I don't think that
gives him straight-up foresight like
Lydia has so it's not like he's
predicting that Liam's going to die it's
just like his wolf spidey sense is going
off and he has all these normal fears
that are just interacting inside his
dream state
Lydia's grandmother didn't quite end up
the way I expected but I'll talk more
about that whenever I get to episode 9
Malia kind of got pushed to the side a
little bit although I did like her Peter
scene it wasn't quite what I expected
either but I feel like she's coming back
to the pack I feel like we just know
that like there's no way that she is
gonna leave the pack for good I had
hoped that her scene with Peter was
gonna be something just crazy diabolical
like he was gonna get all Shakespearean
and Loki on her I am really interested
in the new mystery about her mother
I actually thought that Peter had an
affair with Henry Tate's wife but turns
out her biological mother is someone
totally different with apparently some
coyote leaning tendencies
that's actually pretty adorable let me
know in the comments though do you think
that we're gonna meet her mother this
season are they gonna wait til season
five to do that reveal overall episode
eight was a solid b-plus great character
development for Derek nice leading of
new plot lines with Malia's mother and
Lydia's grandmother Kira did kind of
feel like she got pushed to the side or
pushed into our corner even though her
powers were a critical part of the plan
I think this season the lacrosse scenes
have actually been where she's really
shined okay so moving on to episode 9 so
I'm gonna do my top five moments just
like I normally do in them in my review
so just once again careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet I'll
wait just a second okay ready here we go
number five Parrish on fire this was
probably my favorite moment in general
and the perfect opening to an episode I
just made it my number five because I
wanted to talk about it first
they didn't even bother to explain
things in great detail but it doesn't
matter the title of the episode was
perishable it says it all and fun fact
by the way that deputy that was setting
him on a fire is actually lou ferrigno
son in real life he's the son of the
Hulk the son of the Hulk is a villain
which totally makes sense dissecting
what Parrish is I think he's either a
twist on a creature that we've seen
before or something totally new that the
show's bringing in I don't think he's
just a copy of someone else in the pack
part of this season has been about
expanding the mythology of the show with
all these new creatures we've got
werewolves lightning casue neighs
banshees Wendigos and now whatever
perishes so here's actually a quick list
of mythical creatures that are resistant
to fire there's fire kitsune a's cure is
actually a lightning Kizuna but fire is
the other kind there's dragons Phoenix's
Djinn Firebirds chimera salamander just
explain that one in ancient Greek the
word for salamander means being that
lives in fire and withstands high
temperatures and then there's Capri fire
Giants trophy and fire serpents so of
all those things I think it's more
likely that he's a fire consumed eight
or a Phoenix if you look at the weight
Kyra's powers work she absorbs
electrical discharge I don't know if she
can be burped by electricity but I don't
think so which makes me think that
Parrish is a Phoenix because it looked
like he burnt
in the fire and then regenerated himself
it's possible they could reveal what he
is in the next episode the title is
monstrous so that implies that you know
it's gonna be dealing with his headspace
a little bit
either way I'm really happy that he's
working inside the pack now I think he
just means that he's gonna be an
official member of the pack during
season five please don't die Parrish we
want you back I think the idea parishes
of Phoenix works really well with the
theme of this season you know it's all
about that you know what if someone
actually has to die in order to solve
the problem like perishes powers of
resurrection are gonna be critical to
this season
Derek totally thinks he's gonna die so
what if parish can bring him back to
life let's all hope that that's the case
but I don't think that his powers
whatever they end up being are just
gonna be some throwaway thing like
something interesting I think it's gonna
be critical to the plot this season but
moving on to number four Lydia's
grandmother is explained I was totally
expecting her to end up being the
benefactor you know her background in
tech was a nice twist but I really
appreciated that they took the time to
give her a very detailed backstory like
a very rich history visually the way
they showed those flashbacks was so
amazing just with Lydia walking in and
out of the scenes usually when they do a
scene like that this shot in a really
cool way they post it online at some
point so you can see how they did it
from behind the scenes for anyone that's
interested in filmmaking Jeff Davis
winter breeze tweeting about the episode
is actually really good about posting
behind the scenes pictures but moving on
to number three Liam goes totally crazy
he's having his Jack Nicholson shining
arc like where he slowly goes crazier
and crazier all work and no play make
Liam a dull beta they will have to
resolve this at some point because he
was trying to drown himself in alcohol
at that party despite not being able to
get drunk because of the healing factor
he and Wolverine could totally have a
great conversation about trying to get
drunk just to be clear that all those
printers were printing the Deadpool list
to everywhere in beacon hills like
everywhere there was a printer there was
a list being printed out I do wonder
what made Liam jump to 18 million
dollars though I think that everyone's
values changed a little bit but why is
Liam so much higher than everyone else's
now I think it means that he's just
gonna turn out to be more connected to
the benefactor than we think like he's
gonna be more connected to Meredith but
moving on to number two the shitstorm of
a bonfire party I love the way they set
this up with parish just making us think
that something weird was gonna happen
and everyone was gonna drop at the same
time it was just for shadowing that the
team was going to go after the pack and
try to take them down all
I think they were just playing some
high-pitched tone that only werewolf's
could hear and that was what was
stupefying them I feel like the whole
bonfire was supposed to be the logical
breaking point of the episode like the
ocean moment but it totally got upstaged
by the big benefactor reveal at the end
and moving on to my number one WTF
moment of course Meredith is the
benefactor it was actually a whole lot
going on during the icon house portion
of the episode the reveal was just the
biggest part of that I love bronski's
tapes I bet if you bribed him he would
totally make you a badass mixtape I can
only imagine what bands that he put on
it though that's actually good question
for you guys what tracks do you think
that brunski would put on a mixtape like
what are his favorite bands he seems
like the kind of guy that would listen
to a lot of classic rock like he's stuck
in the past like music did he listen to
when he was in high school I really love
the twist that he was only helping
Meredith but I'm kind of worried this
whole benefactor thing is gonna turn out
to be a simple revenge plot like that's
my biggest fear and when I say that I
mean Meredith getting revenge on
everyone for what happened to her it
feels like it would be a big letdown
after all the time they spent teasing
this out so many interesting things
going on here though I love that they
let brunski be like this super complex
character and then just killed him right
away like it was like we're gonna kill
you but we're gonna let you be super
interesting before we do it he said he
was helping the inmates by killing them
I wonder if it's because of some weird
creepy religious belief or if he was
just out of his mind if any of you guys
watch Game of Thrones the faceless men
and A Song of Ice and Fire
I spent a video talking about it this
weekend they actually have you murder as
a sacrament to their God so whenever
they kill someone it's like they're
performing a religious Rite he was so
great as a creep Oh on the show Peter is
gonna have to get like super extra
creepy to fill that void now wouldnt it
be funny if Peter became the new
caretaker at icann house I would totally
buy that that seems like a job that he
would have it seems like the whole
benefactor operation was localized to
icann house though like Meredith was
only using people from icann house are
extorting them to help her it does make
you wonder though are there other people
helping her outside of eicken house
probably not Kate and Peter just because
they seem like they have their own
agendas like they had their own side
plot and then each of them within that
plot has their own side plot like plots
within plots within plots that totally
seems like a Peter thing to do like have
a plot within a plot if you remember
that Jennifer line from the end of 3a
wherever Peter walks up and kills her
she said you know somehow
people died all around you but you
always end up on top I feel like that's
gonna be the case this season no matter
who dies Peter is gonna end up on top
but let me know in the comments why do
you think that Meredith started the
Deadpool list why does she want to kill
all these supernatural creatures in
beacon hills is it a simple revenge plot
or is it something way more complex I
have so got my fingers crossed that it
is not just a simple revenge plot
overall I gave the episode an A - just
for making Parrish one of the most
interesting characters on the show right
now and for not waiting to pay off the
benefactor reveal there's always a risk
in waiting too long to reveal your big
villain like now we get three full
episodes with Meredith being this
cackling crazy villain on screen and
it's gonna be so much fun I wonder if
they learned their lesson last season
with waiting too long to reveal Jennifer
and 3ei and then it gets in a thousand
three B I would have liked to see a lot
more of Stiles being a supervillain
going crazy all over everyone let me
know what you guys think
do you like finding out who the villain
is in the middle of a season or do you
like it when they wait till the end I
think that revealing them earlier just
lets you have a lot more fun with them
but I can understand not wanting to show
them right away all in all this season
has just gotten better and better with
each episode all the characters are
getting way more complex way more
interesting they've got a lot of
interesting side plot lines so they can
continue on to season five and lacrosse
like the return of lacrosse has been so
much fun especially Kira being on the
little cross team right now the wiki is
listing the remaining three episodes as
airing each week with no breaks episode
10 is monstrous I'm hoping that means
they'll explain Parrish episode 11 is a
promise to the dead so hopefully that
will explain the rest of Meredith's
backstory and they haven't revealed the
title for the finale probably because
it's something spoilery so quick
announcements really important stuff
going on this week Doctor Who is back
this Saturday if you're not watching it
yet you should totally pick it up I've
done a whole bunch of like beginner
explainer videos if you're not sure
what's going on it is the most fun
science fiction you will ever watch you
won't regret it and I'm doing a ton of
videos for it this season like I did for
Game of Thrones I'm also moving to a new
apartment next week and no it does not
look like Derek's loss although that
would be pretty cool I will do a room
tour video after I move into my new
place so I'm really looking forward to
that it'll be a lot of fun so in the
meantime you guys can click here to
start getting ready for Doctor Who and
you can click here for last week's Teen
Wolf thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys tonight
high fives
you